i got really angry today when i was
reading about
all of these stories that are desperate
to claim donald trump
refuses to to denounce white supremacy
and so they do this clever trick where
they're like donald trump refuses to
announce white supremacy
donald trump tells proud boys stand back
and stand by creating like this
manipulation and media where they're
trying to make you think the proud boys
are a white supremacist group
and so what i always say is like look
man the proud boys a lot of things you
can criticize them but they're not a
white supremacist group
the media is desperate to play that up
so the first thing
i want to ask as the leftist narrative
and the media narrative tends to be
that it's actually right-wing militias
and right-wing groups that are starting
all the violence
now look i gotta be honest i've only for
the most part watched your videos to get
a sense of what's going on the ground so
let's hear it from you guys is it really
right-wing groups that are secretly
starting all the riots
no and i think a really good example of
this actually a new york times article
just came out i think it was today
and a uh photographer i believe it was
wanted to go undercover to
confirm that right-wing militias and
extremists were starting this violence
and he actually found the exact opposite
they published that yes wow yeah it came
out today and
and i think we've seen that too you know
you look at portland you look at seattle
you look at some of these other areas
that we've been to and it is
very clearly not right wing
militia is starting the violence i mean
all you have to do is go out there
later than 9 00 pm 10 pm and and see it
for yourself and talk to these people
they're definitely not pro-trump they're
definitely
you know it it's absurd to imply that
like it's crazy to me that you guys can
pump out hours of videos every time you
go to these places
but then you have low information i
guess
i call them low information culture war
belligerence there are people who are
online screaming like we're right you're
wrong
it's actually right winger's doing it
i'm like the only videos i see
are like leftist black black people and
black lives matter going around
throwing bricks and starting fires yet
for some reason you see all these people
on twitter
i wonder if it's just they know they're
lying and they have to
because i mean if they admitted what was
really going on with left-wing violence
they'd lose yeah i think i think it's a
mistake it's like i think when people
see an
image of someone in like militia gear
they just automatically assume they're
like a trumper or on the right and
like shelby was saying and actually i
was kind of even shocked myself when we
actually interview these people these
people are actually on the side of the
protesters they're not
they're not even on the right at all you
mean like the boogaloo boys yeah yeah so
a lot of these folks are not even
you know don't even consider themselves
like republicans a lot of these folks
consider themselves like libertarians
and kind of want to like uh
not i don't want to say overthrow the
system but obviously want less laws and
stuff like that so
that's one thing that you know means
shelby kind of learned on the ground um
you know covering the stuff in
you know different cities too but i mean
that's like that's referencing
these instances where there have been
boogaloo boys i mean for the most part
it's just
black block far left people right like
most places you've been to
yeah i mean and richie and i went to
seattle for chaz
uh the autonomous zone and that was
definitely
not right wing uh people i would say but
you know everyone had guns there and and
everyone
it was upon first impression maybe you
think that because of what
i you know people would assume about
each side but
that's it's just a false narrative i
mean didn't they they pump like hundreds
of rounds into a pickup truck and killed
two kids
oh no they one of them died yeah there
were there were
three shootings i believe in jazz at
different times and
uh did two kids die two people died yeah
even the other the
the while you know reporting in seattle
um you know a lot of these
to get into chats they had like armed
security and then you know while we were
there i was actually able to get one to
get a quick interview with me he
wouldn't do it on camera but i was like
who's who's responsible for this stuff
and they're like oh we're with a john
brown gun club
that was the first time i've ever heard
i'm like the john brown gun club
that's like a left-wing militia and it's
a lovely militia so right there i was
like okay
you know these guys are you know about
the second amendment stuff obviously
when it comes to them but it was
that was the very first time i've ever
heard anything about that then i've
heard you know that name john brown gun
club you know papa multiple times after
our trip in seattle
that's crazy that like they would take
the name john brown gun club and then
now it's like associated with like
marxists and communists or whatever
did you want you wanted to jump in
richie yeah i mean actually to be fair
though while we were in the chas
shelby and i did film a video of
a couple of proud boys four proud boys
beating up a guy pretty badly
really why were they there well
basically we were covering this these
folks who were bringing in
uh flag and they yeah that's right
that's right so their security were
they were the proud boys and after the
flag bearers left
i basically said to like shelby and i
were like well the proud boys are still
here and
as they were on their way out an
individual went up and we were a little
ways back so we didn't see the initial
confrontation that caused it
but we did run up right as the brawling
was starting and i mean you can see the
video on twitter it's it's pretty
it's pretty brutal it's pretty brutal
beating that gave the guy wow
it was like six five versus one yeah and
actually a couple of the proud boys were
armed
and at one point in the video it looks
like the guy's getting beaten actually
is leaning for the
for the gun and that's the kind of
situation where i'm looking like do i
have to form tackle shelby and are we
gonna get back here
well so so as she shakes her head as as
the as the proud boys are basically
the biggest story right now i i can't
believe joe biden decided to shout that
out at the bait because
i immediately got messages from friends
they're like what's a proud boy
and i kid you not some people think it's
like an lgbtq thing
like for real like it was a joke from
gavin mcinnes it was meant to be silly
now it's just like legit thing that gets
shouted out and now they're like the big
story
so uh let me ask you guys out of all of
the riots
you've been to you you mentioned you
know in the chas
shop whatever there was an instance
where the proud boys beat some dude
pretty bad
have you has there been anything else
you've seen across the country
i mean like not like the well yeah
actually just you guys can answer it
just leave it there
that i think is the only example that
we've seen
of the proud boys uh really inserting
themselves into
into a situation like that um we
i mean uh richie went to a proud boys
rally last weekend and i think the
police did a pretty good job of keeping
did
was there even like antifa there or well
there were actually there was a counter
protest
which actually was much much larger by a
magnitude of at least five
wow which was just a couple miles away
but it was a really big park
and so unlike there wasn't there was a
kind of a proud boys rally downtown
in august which got pretty violent which
we weren't present for
but um that was where antifa and you
know the proud boys
whatever the prayer group they were
clashing was that was that was that
patriot pair was that really painful
well i don't really know exactly it's
hard to tell it was run by the patriot
prayer
but there were definitely some people in
there who identified as proud boys
but this weekend it was it was
explicitly proud boys there were
patriot prayer people there as well but
it was almost entirely peaceful only
there was a very small little physical
altercation
where they were basically uh asking the
press who who they were on the way in
and they were forcing out some antifa
press whatever that means i mean
obviously that's there's no credentials
that say
so i'm not sure the validity on that but
there was a small confrontation but i'd
say
other than those two instances no we
haven't seen anything
sorry that was that was even i would say
like that was a proud boys rally so it
wasn't an example of
the proud boys you know going into a
protest or a riot and trying to
you know change the direction of things
or even start arriving yeah
yeah so i mean even the the main thing
the reason why the problems are even
coming up again is because
the violence has gone so bad in these
cities now this is not me saying this is
from folks that i've interviewed in the
proud boys that they've told me it's
just you know
the violence is getting so bad in the
cities they feel like they have to
come in there and like restore law and
order or at least show other americans
hey
you know we stand with law and order we
you know we want to we want you know
this to be restored to how it was um so
that's the big thing that i've been
picking
up is they feel like they got to come in
and kind of you know
just you know just restore something
back um
they declared victory in portland so i
i mean first of all we should probably
describe what the proud boys are because
like we're sitting here acting like
i can straight up say nobody knows who
the proud boys are joe biden brings them
up and then i'm just
i'm bringing an assumption everybody
listen yeah so they're western
chauvinists
they're basically a mixed bag of
politics they're nationalists
and they have previously had violence as
a core function of what their group was
in terms of their degrees do you guys
know all the degrees i know i know the
first
so basically to join the proud boys
first is like you go to a chapter
and you make you make an announcement
that you're not going to apologize for
the for creating the western world
something for that effect
the second degree i think is that you
get
beat up they punch you while you name
five breakfast cereals
like it's because it was a joke it
wasn't a real like you know what i mean
like
this is not an actual uh like gang or
something whatever so then i don't know
what the third one is i might be getting
a tattoo or something
but then i remember the fourth degree
like the highest rank or whatever
was getting into a fight defending
western values
so there was actually a component where
if they went out and antifa started a
fight and they they fought somebody
then they got a rank up or something so
they've been the media likes to to very
like
they give no favors to the proud boys
they get favors all day at least in my
experience to antifa
like antifa doesn't exist it's just an
idea and then you get the proud boys and
it's like well they're far-right
extremists neo-nazi white supremacists
alt-right white nationalists like every
name in the book
they they endorse violence and they're
hunting people down in fact they're
responsible for all of the violence
like i was reading cbs today and they
said
the proud voice comma a white
supremacist group comma and i'm like
that's just ridiculous like you got to
get your facts straight man
and this is what really i i hope it's
clear to everybody listening like
if you guys have no problem saying oh
man the proud boys beat up some guy
really bad
like you're giving us the honest take
you're not protecting any of these
people
but the reality is i don't see far-right
groups starting riots for the past
hundred and ten hundred and twenty days
but how is that that narrative exists
for some reason
you look like you i think it's you know
it's what the the media wants
yeah for people to it's like a huge
media creation it like like i was
like we were speaking before the the
show started is for them to
be brought up at a presidential debate
to me it was really disappointing
because it's like
we're in the middle of a pandemic people
are literally trying to put food on the
table
people are wondering if we're getting a
stimulus check and we're talking about
the problems like you know like i said
if you're in michigan or pennsylvania
you're an undecided voter if there are
any undecided voters though
you're just wondering like how does this
even affect my life so what's the
problem yeah so i think
you know for me this they're becoming
just wait they got too much free cloud
off the presidential debate they're
becoming this huge media creation that's
like
that's not really playing a role in the
in the election and you know for some
reason it's they're like the number one
topic yeah so yeah it's it's just
donald trump is the answer and it's a
mechanism by which
this violence in our streets can be you
know they can blame him ability to blame
him
yeah and with antifa that's obviously
not the case and so the downplaying that
you see there
i mean that's that's no surprise either
so that's that's my answer
is it antifa riding or is it black lives
matter uh i think there's a mix
for sure i mean certain cities that
we've been to kenosha because there's
more anti more of an antifa president
and
in other cities like portland for
example but even but if they're flying
black lives matter flags in portland
yeah there's a combination there there
as well but i'd say in terms of the
organization of the tactics and stuff
like that
like when we're in portland um you know
the blm
activist would come up and take the
stage right around sunset and they'd say
i'm not going near that fence you know
i'm just i'm here to demonstrate
and when we come in near that fence and
they come out and when we're violent
and we bring them here then that defeats
the whole purpose of what we're doing
so we saw a lot of that and then you
know the antifa folks come out at 12 a.m
when all the cable news you know they're
no longer live and there's no more
correspondence out there and it's no
longer a party-like atmosphere
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you